мотор працюємо Ну що спробуємо дати нове
життя цьому напівзабутому шлядееру
запускай нам ту значить доведеться
обирати разом мера бажано не путініста і
не корупціонера бажано не мудозвона
звісно не регіонала просто квота
дозвонів у міськраді
заманала не зробити з наскудобу не
вігнати нас халепу не підтримуй більше
добу не підтримуй більше гепу слід
сьогодні об'єднатись виборцям усіх
прошарків щоби завжди залишалось
українське місто Харків голосують
інженери кожен з плюсарізантехнік
іратехнік піротехнік
піротехнік голосують інженери
кожен слюсар і самтехнік піротехнік
піротехнік
[музика]
уху Yeah